if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump's
obama
look at that
look at that look at that
man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
that
of november
all right hey everybody i genuinely have
no idea why the audio on my intros
wasn't
working everything
seems fine here i can't find any
technical aspects that are wrong
but uh i guess we're just gonna have to
um sort of like skip it today i don't
know it's it's all very strange
uh it's sad it's sad but we are covering
the continued johnny depp amber heard
defamation trial let's see if we have
audio here relationships he was in
you know
just pretty normal stuff we do
um okay well listen let's get into it
they're gonna go to a break in a bit and
then we'll have time to do other stuff
so let's let's listen and observe and
learn and see everything that's going on
this is currently a some kind of
forensic examiner of something let's
figure it all out together
i i guess we're in a sidebar here okay
let's continue
mr banya what did you find about the
results
of the top web pages that you determined
after ms heard's initial allegations and
then again after the publication of the
op-ed
yeah so after the initial allegations in
2016
i found that the majority of them had to
do with the alleged abuse
and then after i
realized that the the ones
the web pages that were dealing with the
alleged abuse then started talking about
is is drinking and drug
uh drink drinking and doing drugs so it
appeared to me that um
you know they became negative after 2016
but then after 2018 they even included
you know the the alleged abuse but also
included this the
trump uh drinking and drug use
did you
form any opinions about the results that
didn't refer to the allegations of abuse
that didn't
i formed an opinion that um
[Music]
i'm not following your question i'm
sorry that's right we can move on
um did any of the results that you
analyzed refer to mr depp's work ethic
no
did you form um
any overall opinions about the results
um in the web pages that you looked at
following ms heard's accusations of
abuse
yes uh as i stated um you know prior to
2016 the web pages were just about his
daily life and career
after the 2016 marker point they tended
to
include the majority of them included
you know the allegations of abuse and
then after the 2018 op-ed uh the ones
that included the allegations of abuse
we're also talking about drinking and
drug use what was your overall view of
the connotation of those results then
yeah so mr depp was portrayed in a
negative connotation after the
2016 allegations of abuse and even more
so after the 2018.
you mentioned you also looked at q
scores as part of your analysis how are
q scores calculated
so q score is um it's a it's a survey of
1800 people that happens twice a year
and
um
what they do is uh it's internet-based
and uh they they measure how well a
celebrity or a brand is known how how
much they're liked and how much they're
disliked q scores you know include
sports figures celebrities even cartoon
characters brands
so that's my q score is reportedly off
the charts the doctors are saying
reflects the q score analysis that you
prepared yes okay tom could we have um
demonstrative c please
and mr banya what does this tell us
about the the q square analysis that you
completed
yes so what this is saying again you
know these spikes are the google trends
that you've already seen but what i've
overlaid are his q scores shown in the
red green and purple area
and and as you recall i wanted to find
out his q score prior to the
allegations of abuse in 2016 where he
had a positive q score of 11 and a
negative q score i'm sorry a positive q
score of 35 and a negative q score of
11. and then i looked at the q scores
after
and then after the op-ed
and what did you determine about those q
scores
yeah so what you can see here his
positive q score uh which is represented
in red was at 35 and that was prior to
the alleged abuse and the restraining
order then after that
his q scored a positive q score dropped
to a 31. and what that's saying is less
people liked him
after
fewer people sir the the date of the
2016 alleged abuse and then his negative
q score went up from an 11 to a 16 which
is telling you that more people disliked
him uh during that time frame
and what did you find about the final um
q scores that you looked at for mr doug
yeah then you can see the q score c that
i have there in purple
his positive q score
went from a 31 to a 29 his negative few
score went from a 16 to a 15. so now his
p his positive q score dropped again
from a 31 to a 29
meaning less people
had a positive impression i you know my
instinct so far here is like i'm kind of
leaning towards depp is the one who's
getting the better of this trial but
what's interesting is
what we might call
the volatility of this metric
it seems to have been higher before any
of this stuff right i mean i don't know
i'm just kind of looking at it as a lay
person scores during this snapshot of
time i wanted to understand what they
were before
during and after the op-ed and what this
tells me is his positive q score went
from a 35 to a 29
and then his negative went from an 11 to
a 15. so what the q scores is telling me
is the public perception of mr deb uh
has been damaged you know they they
like him less and they dislike him more
based on all of the analyses that you
completed in this case what are your
final opinions about
mr depp's reputation over this period of
time
yeah so my opinions are that you know mr
depp was not portrayed in a negative
connotation prior to the 2016
allegations of abuse
and then mr this seems like the weakest
part of the depth case to just to be
totally frank with everybody like this
doesn't seem very compelling for
defamation and then more so
after the 2018 washington post op-ed but
it's all about how the lawyers can weave
it together in closing there's no doubt
you know the public thinks he's damaged
they think uh
less
likely of him his positive excuse q
score has gone down and they don't like
him even more because his negative q
score went from the 11 to the 15.
i have no further questions of this
witness around all right ladies and
gentlemen let's go ahead and take our
afternoon recess of 15 minutes do not
discuss the case and do not do the
outside research just stay right there
for a second sir
so uh presumably subject to
cross-examination after our tea and
crumpets break that is upcoming here
we have plenty to talk about too so i'm
i
welcome and relish
this uh short break that we're going to
get here
all right
since you're in the middle of your
testimony did not discuss your case even
with the attorneys at this point or your
testimony okay sir okay all right you
can step down we'll be back in about 15
votes okay
all right so they'll be back in about 15
minutes and we're going to keep watching
all of it thank you sir
sure jerry
sure okay sorry sir whoa that that got a
little bit out of control uh welcome
everybody it is really great to have you
here uh this is going to be much more
relaxed than yesterday during the prompt
rally we had our rare sunday stream
and it was the absolute worst that
donald trump looked since the beginning
of this entire thing it's it's
i don't know how many of you were with
me yesterday
but just because we have the time check
out a couple of these extremely glitchy
moments at one point yet
trump made up a candidate's name
he didn't seem to know who he had
endorsed and then he said we endorsed
j.p
and then he said we endorsed j.d mandel
which is a portmanteau of
jd vance and josh mandel he didn't
endorse josh mandel but somehow he still
mentioned mandel's last name this
primary is tomorrow i mean this this is
wacky check this out or they're waiting
for one race you know we've endorsed dr
oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
and he's doing great
he's doing it's amazing how well jd
mandela is doing my favorite thing is
actually when he says jp right and he
looks over like did we endorse jp i
don't even know who's jp it's not clear
but we endorsed him i think
um
couple other moments from this just
glitchy as all hell
here is one where he tries to say mitt
romney and it doesn't go well at all
even though it was totally made up that
was about a guy named a rhino named mitt
romney
mitt romney you see how the glitch noise
is like a record skipping it's like
listen to that it's very very strange
that was about a guy named a rhino named
mitt romney
that's quite a noise we need that noise
on the sound board
i named a rhino named mitt romney
mitt
romney reminds me of obama
uh and then i have one more here
here is a uh a bovine investigation
billy the cud
i've had more investigations than jesse
james billy they could
[Laughter]
it's just so weird if by by the way
if biden did this they would have been
calling for his removal that's what
they're waiting for they're waiting for
one race you know we've endorsed dr oz
we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
if you're jd vance and you've had to
like grovel to trump for months to get
him to endorse you and then two days
before your primary trump goes
my choice is j.d mandel
how furious are you that you've had to
totally humiliate yourself i mean it's
it's just crazy
crazy
uh all right let me give away a
membership kevin gouldy just gifted a
membership that's number one for the day
really appreciate you kevin that
membership goes to christopher
lavenger christopher lavinger gets that
free membership really appreciate that
in a in a really strong and powerful way
okay let's look at a couple of other
things here
uh let's see what else i had
um
uh you know i i still am kind of unclear
about this
let me let me pull up the article
so
i know some of you remember that at the
very very start
of the russian invasion of ukraine
a couple of doctors emailed me and they
said david sir sure
we think i think
that vladimir putin is sick he seems ill
he just seems like he's sick
and i said to all of you this is
extremely speculative
but
it would explain a lot of things even
though it's completely speculative
and then about 10 days ago this video
was released of vladimir putin at a
table
gripping the table like he needs it to
stay afloat
um he's like melted into his chair
his left hand is shaking
he it's just bad it's just bad and then
i said listen it's still speculative but
he looks bloated
he looks
very very sick
and then two days ago an article came
out in the british tabloid the sun and
it said putin has parkinson's and cancer
and he's about
to
have major surgery
and i said the sun for me is not
reputable enough for me to be ready to
report it as a story
now we're up to the new york post
now
still
the new york post is basically the print
version of fox news it's it's i still
don't love it as a source here's the
video by the way that i'm talking about
um but now the report is putin is going
to undergo cancer surgery and transfer
power albeit temporarily to his ex-fsb
chief now do am i now a hundred percent
sure this is true no
this is not
reputable in the sense that i would like
to see for me to say it's definitely
true but we've gone from
idle speculation
to
video
sort of seeming to support it
to reports in a tabloid to reports in a
not super reliable american media outlet
the new york post
we seem to be getting closer and closer
to yeah putin is indeed very sick
so everybody can kind of
use whatever standard you will apply to
the sourcing that we have but we're
getting closer and closer and closer and
to me
a deathbed putin or a very ill putin
seems
very dangerous
very very dangerous so that's where we
are at this point in time
i want to say thank you to nicole bonier
nicole is uh new member number two today
and has gifted a membership that
membership goes to kyle
shagnan
kyle shagnan thank you so much nicole
for the gift
also want to say thank you to mama kell
and jen here each subscribing via twitch
prime over on
twitch now if there has ever been
an important a time
as today to take away bezos bucks from
jeff bezos
i can't think of it so just remember if
you have an amazon prime subscription
you get a free twitch prime which you
can use here for free and it takes money
from bay zoats
and sends it to us which is a beautiful
beautiful thing oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad right
okay
uh here's another little something
for me
anytime a platform describes itself as a
free speech platform i assume that
that's code for speech that we like let
me explain what i mean
youtube doesn't describe itself as a
free speech platform it's the biggest
video platform in the world
so
there's terms of service
there's content that's not allowed there
are things that are not allowed they
don't describe themselves as a free
speech platform but most content is okay
on youtube
when i hear
these right-wing platforms say we are a
free speech platform
i'm hearing
it is not a free speech platform check
out the restrictions on trump's truth
social or correctly said truth social
okay let me see if i can even do this
here's all the stuff that's not allowed
on the free speech platform
okay oh hold on chat is stuck oh okay
we've unstuck it that's weird
okay
let's see here are all the things that
you can report on truth social illegal
activity and behavior content that
depicts illegal or criminal acts and
threats of violence now the complexity
with that if you're a free speech
platform is
you can only determine whether something
is illegal
in
a court of law
what i mean by that is
it's pretty oppressive from a free
speech standpoint to say
it will be up to their opinion of the
law
what who are you that's not due process
that's weird
intellectual property infringement
impersonating another account or
business infringing on intellectual
property rights that doesn't sound like
free speech that sounds like a corporate
kowtow
sensitive content depictions of violence
gore or nudity i guess any uh depictions
of the january 6 trump riots wouldn't be
allowed
under age content sexually explicit
content involving underage children
sounds like they've declared themselves
judge jury and executioner on all of
this stuff
prostitution solicitation or advertising
for illegal sexual activity or sex for
hire guess matt gates can't be on the
platform huh
it's kind of weird privacy violations
violate or post content that violates a
person's privacy rights
illegal sales
sale of or promotion of illegal drugs
counterfeit services and goods or
illegal pro products and services so
basically
this free speech platform truth social
has the exact same terms of service
as every other social media platform
there's nothing special about it there's
nothing particularly free about the
speech that you're allowed to have
anybody surprised by this
it's judge judy and executioner exactly
so anyway
not not very uh
not very inspirational
here's another really weird one and
hopefully we'll have more information
about this tomorrow nbc news just put
out this bizarre statement they put it
out absent any context
see if you can make heads or tails out
of it
a note to our readers
a review by nbc news found 11 articles
written by a reporter over the last year
that didn't meet our standards for
original material
the article contained passages from
other news organizations used without
attribution okay so 11 articles were
plagiarized
in all cases the passages were not
central to the stories but they
contained supplemental or background
material that didn't represent original
reporting an editor's note has been
placed on each of the articles and the
passages that were plagiarized have been
removed
what a bizarre vague statement
i'm guessing eventually we will learn
what the 11 articles are and who the
author is
but right now i have absolutely no idea
so seems to be some kind of a plagiarism
issue over on nbc news that's pretty
interesting
uh it's a cover your ass letter yes
exactly
exactly that's that's absolutely what it
is
so that's all going on um let's listen
to a couple of voicemails as we stand by
here
uh let's listen
uh pac-man just watch your video by the
way this is the san antonio troll
usually he calls in and criticizes me
for things i haven't said let's see what
he says today about that lady that
thinks jim carrey is uh
joe biden um
as far as the oh excuse me
as far as the uh
looks like the psychosis thing i don't
think it's um
[Music]
any of that
i actually have a family member
a very close family member who is a q
and on casualty
and um
it's not just him it's several people
this gym guy started the stream carry
thing a long time ago it's not even
wearing a mask it's literally jim carrey
as a body double and jim carrey the
thing is jim carrey is supposed to
secretly be a white hat
and i know it's insane it's absolutely
nuts and it's hardcore trump support
even though jim carrey is not even close
he's always been a democratic
man i'm i'm really bored with the san
antonio troll
so um
in regards to like economics so when it
comes to girls who are getting like too
much attention um from men and then not
enough from
society
girls getting too much attention from
men
and not enough from society
do you think it's because
they get too much attention from them
that they're not getting enough
attention from society
or
do you think that they're not getting
enough attention from society so that's
why they're getting more attention
from them
and we will ban men
i don't know what whitney's talking
about
hey david um is there any reason why you
take these
infuriatingly
minuscule sips of water just just do a
little bit more water
uh to ease
uh everyone's concerns please why fish
small sips of water
i can tell you why
uh
when i'm on
when i'm broadcasting i don't want to
take a sip and have that thing where you
choke on the water and then i'd cough
for five minutes
so i just go real little
real little sips i want to minimize the
possibility of having one of those uh
one of those incidents because if you do
here's what can happen let me see if i
can find it this has happened to fox
news host fox news let's see if i do
cough
it's bad when it happens
um
oh you know what oh my god
i forgot about this i'm not going to be
able to find that i covered this clip
early on in the covid situation
the i rem this dad is coughing the
entire interview look check this out i
think as time goes forward
hopefully doctors and scientists will
get a better
better handle on the whole situation
fortunately from what i understand you
know
it is contagious but
the death rate is is pretty low
this was like before march even this was
february of 2020. so um
yeah i understand the fear yeah well we
can see you still have a cough what do
the doctors say about your own condition
moving forward as we wrap this up
um excuse me
let me get some of that
they said um
yeah i'm fine i got tested twice uh
negative both times
uh the cough
probably just uh nerves yeah yeah
i cough when i'm nervous all the time
uh so anyway that was that was weird but
that's why i take small sips of water
okay guys super chat coming in from
industry
marjorie taylor green on the street with
acosta is exactly what happens when you
corner a pathological liar they freak
out and won't let you speak while
walking away yeah we have a clip on that
on today's podcast if that topic is
interesting to you we we're covering
that pretty extensively um welcome to
everybody coming in we're just in a very
short break in the johnny depp trial
uh i do want to say thank you to
god i want to say thank you to nobody
nobody okay we are about to get back on
the record here
okay we have one exhibit
okay one exhibit oh good
that means you're only down one right
that's right okay perfect this is 1639
all right thank you
all right
go ahead and get the jury
is the audio level okay everybody let me
know if the the the court audio is too
low in my mix it sounds okay but i'm
always uh you guys are in charge here
y'all y'all are in charge
uh
oh hold on a second i gotta ban someone
this guy sleepy joe biden thought he was
gonna come in here and troll us buh-bye
that's a perma
don't even bother appealing dude it's
just not even worth it okay don't even i
don't even want to see your name pop up
in the appeals list
uh it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be adjudicated in a
friendly way that's for damn sure
okay we're continuing here with uh a
sort of like um
i guess this guy's an expert on
it's almost like popularity and
reputational metrics i don't even know
thanks to blueberry babe for gifting a
subscription via twitch i really
appreciate that i will be live wednesday
night with the republican senate debate
from pennsylvania as the folks say these
days
and it should be interesting
oh and thanks to blueberry gabe babe for
gifting another subscription
all right cross-examination okay here we
go this might be good afternoon mr banya
good afternoon
mr banya you understand that this case
is about the op-ed in december 2018
correct
i understand this case to be about the
allegations of domestic abuse both
as it relates to the 2016 and the
republication of that in the 2018
washington post op-ed you understand
that mr depp is only suing amber about
the op-ed from december 2018 correct
my understanding is
i can base my understanding on my
analysis which includes
the 2016 allegations that's your
analysis but do you understand what mr
depp
is suing amber for in this case is it up
to him to understand objection your
honor to the extent it calls for a legal
conclusion exactly all right i'll just
say sustain the objection next question
in this case yes did you understand that
mr depp was only suing for the op-ed
about the op-ed yes okay
and it's he was not mr depp was not
suing amber in this case from his
complaint
about the accusations she made in 2016
correct
that is my understanding all right
and you're not able to separate out how
mr depp's reputation was impacted from
the op-ed in 2018 versus how it was
impacted when miss heard filed for
divorce in 2016.
correct that's not correct
okay
this could get interesting
yes sir
thank you
mr vaughn you took a deposition in this
case
yes i did and i was asking you the
questions in that case is that right
that's correct okay
and
you took that deposition on march 21st
2022
that's correct okay and you were
under oath at the time correct
yes okay and you're under earth to tell
the truth correct correct
can you turn to page 83
of your transcript oh boy which is on
the 21st page of the
i'm here
okay you see line nine
yes and i ask you are you able to
separate out how mr depp's reputation
was impacted from the op-ed versus how
it was impacted by when miss heard filed
for divorce
and your answer was no correct correct
okay
and you're not able to separate out how
mr depp's reputation was impacted from
the op-ed in 2018 versus the publicity
surrounding when mr depp sued the sun
newspaper in the united kingdom when a
son writer called mr def a wife beater
correct
are you still reading from my deposition
no i'm asking you a question now please
repeat that you're not able to separate
out how mr depp's reputation was
impacted from the op-ed in 2018 versus
the publicity surrounding when mr depp
sued the sun newspaper in the united
kingdom when a son writer called mr depp
a wife beater objection compound your
honor
sustained
you're not able to separate out how mr
depp's reputation was impacted from the
op-ed in 2018 versus the publicity
surrounding when mr depp sued the sun
newspaper in the united kingdom correct
my analysis shows that
the um
the web documents that i reviewed after
the 2018 allegations respectively this
is a yes or no question this is a yes or
no question
please repeat the question you're not
able to separate out how mr depp's
reputation was impacted from the op-ed
in 2018 versus the publicity surrounding
when mr depp sued the sun newspaper in
the united kingdom
that was not part of my analysis to
carve that out
and you didn't you wouldn't you were not
able to separate it correct i didn't try
to okay and and so you don't you
couldn't
i didn't try it okay
and you understand
that the article mr depp sue the song
imagine not running a mile in six
minutes and being like you were not able
to run a mile in six minutes right i
don't know i didn't try the new
fantastic piece film correct
uh i don't recall if that's one of the
articles i reviewed
did you unders do you know if that
article came out
before miss heard's op-ed i don't know
now
you're not offering an opinion as to how
the op-ed from is heard in december 2018
impacted mr depp's career correct
repeat that please you're not offering
an opinion as to how the op-ed from
misheard in december 2018
impacted mr depp's career correct okay
and you're not offering an opinion as to
how the op-ed for misheard in december
2018 impacted mr depp's reputation
what i'm doing is i'm it's a yes or no
are you doing
are you offering opinion to that or not
uh
my opinion is related to his public
image you're not offering an opinion as
to how the op-ed for misheard in
december 2018
impacted mr depp's reputation correct
am not talking to
exactly about his reputation correct
and you're not offering an opinion as to
how the op-ed for misheard in december
2018 impacted mr depp's public image
correct
i mean i'm offering an opinion that
after the 2018. yes or no sir
it's a yes or no you're not offering an
opinion as to how the op-ed from
misheard in december 2018 impacted mr
depp's public image
i am turn to your deposition transcript
please
oh man
if you go to page 74
he the questions are all phrased as
asking for confirmation of a negative of
what he's not
doing which is fine it's just it's
muddling it
[Applause]
and you see lion area there yes
you see line one
starting on line one i asked you and
you're not going to testify how the
december 2018 op-ed impacted mr depp's
public image
answer that's correct
that that was your testimony at the time
okay well well the that was perception
is this sorry that was yours at the time
correct okay yes and that was your
answer on march 21st 2022 correct
the yes the date of the deposition so
that was a month and a half ago right
okay
and you're not offering an opinion as to
whether the op-ed for misheard made mr
debt more hirable or less hirable
correct correct okay
as to the articles that came up in the
google searches that you spoke about it
was you made the determination whether
the articles had a quote negative
connotation or not right
correct okay
and so that's just your view of an
article had a negative connotation about
mr depp right
yes that's my opinion that they had a
negative connotation right so if an
article criticizes mr deff's acting for
example you're not considering that
article as having a negative connotation
about mr depp correct
repeat that please so if an article
criticizes mr depp's acting you're not
considering that article as having a
negative connotation about mr deb
correct correct okay
now in your analysis of google spikes
the highest spike in searches for mr
depp was in january
2004 correct correct
okay and can
i guess you guys have it can you put up
the demonstrative 1236
um
my instinct from the direct examination
was this isn't the best witness and this
this may not go well for the for the
depth side
okay
so the if i'm understanding you
correctly
a is where the most searches were
conducted about for johnny depp correct
correct
and that's from january 2004 correct
correct so that was 18 years ago correct
okay and that was when miss heard was 18
years old well i don't know okay
the top spike you mark as a hundred
correct
i did not mark that but google trends uh
identified that spike as 100. and where
it says
100 you don't know how many people
actually search for johnny depp i think
that's just the baseline starting point
i think that's all that is algorithm
marks the highest point of search as a
hundred and then everything is compared
to that as a ratio or a percent
so if you notice that a is a hundred
everything else is lower than that
because everything is being compared to
that highest point right so you don't
know how many people actually did the
search for johnny depp in
january 2004 correct correct nobody does
google doesn't release that information
all right
i don't know and you don't know if it's
actually human beings doing these
searches
correct
as opposed to as opposed to bots or
something like that
i i did not do an analysis to determine
if there's a bot or a human being but
google trends is a tool that's going to
show you during a time frame the highest
point of search interest as a hundred
okay
but you don't know if it you don't know
if it's humans bots
my cat doing the searches correct
objection asked and answered your
sustained next question cats
sir your cat must be very stupid to live
with you i can't imagine it's your cat
in all of these google spikes sure miss
herd's op-ed never came up as one of the
top three searches in any of the google
spikes correct
well that is correct because google
trends is based on a search of a word or
a name and because mr depp's name was
not mentioned in that op-ed google
trends did not pick that up
so person does a search for johnny depp
and the op-ed doesn't come up correct
in my analysis the op-ed did not come up
okay
and in fact
the red line the red dotted line
all the way to the right that shows
when the op-ed was published on december
18 2018 correct
yes okay
and the searches are actually going
down
right after the red line correct
as opposed to the searches in 2004
look at the red line look at the red
dotted line and you have two you have
two points here right there
those go down
from the time council i need a
protractor to answer that question okay
and isn't it true that the next
i guess spike happens
in march of 2019 correct
right
there yes
and do you know that it was march of
2019
when mr depp sued amber heard in this
case
no i didn't look at that date right you
didn't look at any articles
for the for that for this bullet correct
that's correct
and
since miss herds op-ed came out on
december 18 2018
you would agree with me that by
definition all the spikes you analyzed
before december 18 2018 could not have
been caused by the op-ed right correct
so articles about mr depp's drug use
before december 2018 could not have been
caused by the op-ed correct
correct okay
and
you
in this chart analyze only two spikes
after the op-ed isn't that right
that is correct okay
and the first spike you analyzed after
december 2018
is v correct yes
and
is that from
is that january
2020
roughly yes okay so that's january 2020
is over a year
after the op-ed by miss hurt correct
that's correct okay
and then the next spike you analyzed was
t correct
yes
and that was in approximately july 2020
correct okay so that was
a year and a half after misheard's op-ed
correct
yes okay
and again none of the articles and then
you and then for vnt if i understand it
you then analyze the top three
searches that come up that came up or
the top three websites that came up
after a search correct okay
and none of the articles you analyzed in
those google spikes after the op-ed were
the op-ed correct correct okay
and isn't it true that the headlines of
the articles over a year after the op-ed
that you analyzed were about mr depp
suing the sun in the uk
for a son writer calling mr deck a wife
peter
you would have to pull those articles
back up but i don't have those in front
of me
isn't it true that the article you see
and and just so i understand it vnt that
would mean there were six articles
correct that you analyzed yes okay and
isn't it true that the article on
february 26 2020 the headline was quote
johnny depp's disturbing alleged text
messages read aloud in court as libel
lawsuit begins
again i don't have that article in front
of me i did produce those as part of my
analysis i don't have that in front of
me if you'd like to show it to me and
you understand that that was about the
lawsuit against the sun in the uk not
about the op-ed correct
again i did not have that in front of me
and the other another article that came
up on february 20. so these questions
are not meant to be actually addressed
it's just to get the question on the
record
quote let's burn amber texts allegedly
sent by johnny depp about x read in
court
i mean if you want to talk about these
articles but we need to bring them up
this is your opinion you don't you don't
recall what articles you analyzed i mean
there's a lot of articles here i don't i
didn't memorize each
title there was there were six articles
that you analyzed
in the
almost two years after the op-ed all
right
can you bring those up and we can talk
about them and on july 19th 2020 the
headline was
quote hollywood nervously awaits fallout
from explosive johnny depp trial
you don't you don't recall one way or
the other whether that was
one of the articles in either v or t
again
i know if you want to bring up my
documents i know document 9 j 9 0
9
k
and 9 m
are mentioning the op-ed
again i don't have those and when you
say and when you say mentioning the
op-ed does that mean that it just
references that mr depp sued amber heard
in fairfax no it talks about how he's
alleged to have abused her as it relates
to the op-ed doesn't it say i mean
another headline from july 19 2020 the
headline was quote hollywood nervously
awaits fallout from explosives i would
love if any of our lawyers are in the
chat today to tell us whether this line
of questioning would be useful to amber
heard against the sun in the uk correct
objection asked and i asked about that
overruled
again
i would like to talk about these
articles but i need to see them
and on july 19 2020 the headline was
quote johnny depp versus amber heard all
the nasty bits of the uk trial and it's
all nasty
that was in
point t correct
again i do not have that list in front
of me
if you'd like to bring that up we could
talk about it and you understood that
was about the lawsuit against the sun in
the uk correct i do not
okay and on july 19 2020 the headline
was quote
johnny depp
claims in the sun he beat ex-wife
complete lies court told that was the
quote correct
i don't see that here
that was in your report correct
i i would have to look at the documents
again i would be happy to discuss them
if you would bring those up and then you
previously had a chart that had articles
from november 2020 correct
i'm sorry say that you previously had a
chart that included articles from
november 2020 correct objection you're
under maybe we approach it okay sure
uh quite quite a scene here with the i
mean yeah i guess many of you in the
chat think the whole point of this is
just to confuse the jury and to take all
of this stuff out for them to go you
know what
we don't really know what if anything
this has to do with any of this stuff
you understood it was mr depp's decision
to sue the sun correct
i i don't know that's not part of my
analysis now
you talked about q scores in your test
in your direct testimony correct correct
i don't know q and and you testified
about three particular q scores for mr
depp right
three periods of time is the q scores
that i analyzed and you're not offering
an opinion as to why mr def q scores
change correct
that's correct
and q scores can go up and down for
actors for any sort of reason correct
that's possible
you recall testifying that they any sort
is a little vague
yeah they can go up and down for many
different reasons so you're not offering
an opinion that mr depp's q scores were
damaged because of miss herd's op-ed
correct that's correct
and in comparing the q scores from
before the op-ed to the q scores after
the op-ed
mr depp's q scores dropped by two points
correct
i i don't have those q scores in front
of me but if if you're looking at them
we can show we can show the third page
of this demonstrative
what was your question please his mr
depp's positive q scores from b to c
dropped
by two points correct yes you're not an
expert on statistics correct correct
and even though you're not an expert you
have an idea about what the term
statistically significant means correct
yes
and statistical significance is a
measure of whether your findings are
meaningful right
yes i don't think you need statistics
well it's more about whether they could
be a result of chance we drop in two
points in positive q score correct
there absolutely is when you're ordering
q scores on the
points of time mr ben you go to your
deposition page 113
[Applause]
which is on 29. i like how this guy's
name is being put in the subtitles as
banya which is the spanish word for
bathroom
okay
at 10
at lion page 113 line 10 it says it
sounds like basically what this guy does
is do internet searches he's not a
statistician he's not offering opinions
as to why these are the things
he's just like here are numbers
a difference what i'm talking about is
how we use q scores in the industry when
you see a q score from dropping from a
31 to a 29 there's an issue is this
somebody you really want to hire to
endorse your products or your service no
you probably not you want to look into
why why what is going on in the public
uh to to make these q scores and you can
do that other thing you know exactly the
third element of the bathroom five or
six points of drop and q score correct
correct okay
now
and it shows here that mr depp's
negative q score actually got better
from point b to point c correct correct
so that's actually better for mr deb
correct correct okay
and you understood
you understand that dr allen jacobs
reviewed your opinions in this case yes
and you understand that dr jacobs
reviewed additional q score data correct
yes okay can we please put up
plaintiff's exhibit 889. my instinct is
this isn't a good
witness for depp but it may not make a
difference in the end let me know what
you think
mr banya do you understand this as a
chart of mr depp's q scores
from winter 2012 through summer of 2021
yes
do you have any reason to question
the q scores
that are that are just that are shown in
this chart
uh like i said my deposition i have not
received the actual data to build this
chart but i don't have any reason to to
not believe that this is accurate as i
understand that q scores are
performed on a celebrity like mr dapp
twice a year correct
yes so there's winter
of a particular year
and then there's
uh summer of a particular year yes and
the winter scores come out around
february is that right
but i don't have that information in
front of me but it sounds right and so
would you know when the summer scores
come out uh i don't okay
okay
and this
chart shows
well
permission to publish this chart as a
demonstrator of your honor any objection
i don't think this witness has laid an
appropriate foundation for your honor he
said he has no reason to question the q
scores out loud as a demonstration
that's fine
and so this chart shows mr depp's
positive and negative q scores
correct correct
and the positive q scores are in blue
that's
correct
can you blow it up a little bit michelle
and
and the negative q scores are in red
that doesn't look great yes okay
objection your honor may we approach
first
i mean so the point here is that it
certainly looks like his positive scores
actually improve after the amber heard
op-ed which would run counter to the
case of the depth trial
um
[Music]
now of course we could say well that
might be the case in some limited public
opinion but studio still didn't want
anything to do with the guy
i don't know
it's
it's interesting
mr banya the positive q score for mr
depp in the winter of 2012
is 42 correct
it's in between yeah it's in between 40
and 45. is this guy going to cry
and
if we if
did you check this actual q scores that
um
mr jacobs
demonstrated in his report
no my analysis was a snapshot of time i
wanted to know johnny depp's q scores
directly before
the 2012 allegations the 2016
allegations of abuse and after
okay
and you see here that the positive q
scores for mr depp
dropped from 42 in the winter of 2012
to
35
in the summer of 2016 correct
yes that's a seven point drop correct
yes and that's before
miss heard had heard the divorce filing
correct that's correct
and that
drop in mr depp's positive q scores
could have nothing to do
with miss heard's op-ed correct
correct
and that drop could have nothing to do
with the allegations misheard made
after the divorce filing correct correct
and
would you agree that
the
positive
q scores
actually start to show an increase for
mr depp
after the op-ed
there's a decrease and then there's an
increase yeah
and the same for the negative
debt
q scores
there's a bit of a positive
and then it goes down correct yes
so really the op-ed had no effect on mr
depp's q scores correct
as i mentioned my analysis looked at the
snapshot of time and it shows that he
was harmed
you know from before
the
allegations of abuse in 16 to after the
op-ed in 2018. you looked at three q
scores
and you could have looked at one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen
seventeen
eighteen i won't even count the twenty
twenty one scores eighteen q scores
correct yep okay and you looked at three
right that's correct
and and that's what you're basing your
opinion on that the op-ed damaged
mr depp's q scores yeah so we knew that
that's right
my question is yes or no your council
can come
back i wanted to do
i wanted to analyze sir if you could
just answer his questions all right
that's fine
i didn't hear your question
you looked at three q scores instead of
18 q scores correct that's correct
and did you look at the q scores at all
after the dan wooten article that came
out in april of
of uh 2018
objection asked an answer johnner i
don't think i asked that overruled out
that
no okay
thank you i have nothing there all right
redirect
uh mr banya on cross-examination you
were asked some questions about uh the
fact that you made a determination
about which of these articles had a
negative connotation do you recall that
yes
is that something that you do in uh
situations other than in your analysis
in this case
yeah yeah so in non-litigation when
we're building brand monetization
strategies especially if you're going to
work with a celebrity celebrity or an
athlete you want to look at what's going
on out there you know about that
personality you know because celebrities
and athletes you know cue scores can go
up and down you want to analyze the time
and see what's going on out in the media
do i really want my client to license in
a celebrity that
there's problems out there or an athlete
so yes it's important to look at this
and i believe you were asked um whether
you're offering an opinion in this case
about the impact of the op-ed on mr
depp's public image do you recall that
yes and i believe you testified that you
are offering an opinion on that is that
right yes what's that opinion well the
opinion is that uh
he's portrayed in a negative
connotation after that date
and with respect to the q scores that
you analyzed um mr nadelhof was asking
you about the three points in time that
you looked at
why in your opinion was it appropriate
to look at just those three q scores as
i was trying to explain you know q
scores do go up and down we're analyzing
a period of time we want to see what's
happening right before an event
during that event and if there's another
event after that event and that is our
area of analysis
uh so that's why just these three sets
of q scores are the appropriate way to
analyze no disrespect to consultants
this looks exactly like the type of guy
who sells something that's not super
necessary for companies best way with
anybody since you are subject to recall
but since you are an expert you are
allowed to stay in the courtroom if you
wish okay okay all right thank you sir
all right you can step down sure
all right your next witness
you're on a i believe we're calling
aaron fellati by deposition oh okay
could you put i'm sorry could you bring
my phone you approached there's two
exhibits that we have okay
all right well we're
all right they're going to be bringing
in the next witness i want to say thanks
to john abell who just signed up on my
website joinpackman.com
i invite you to sign up on that website
you can use the coupon code obama obama
to um obtain a membership at a great
discount also thanks to everybody who's
been subscribing via twitch prime
including under the screen
and many many others
we will be live wednesday evening with
the pennsylvania republican senate
debate mehmet oz and dave mccormick and
a whole bunch of other
very very wacky people are running in
that race we do have the ohio
oh maybe i should stream tomorrow night
jd mandel tomorrow night is up for
election in ohio if
i guess if there's going to be live
results of that i could potentially
stream that
does anybody know if there's enough
elections tomorrow that it would be
worth doing a results stream tomorrow
night i don't know
um
i on betrothed social no i am not on
betrothed social
thanks to
chur
to the game
for the twitch prime subscription i
appreciate that yeah if anybody knows
like the the totality of what's up for
election tomorrow send an email to info
davidpakman.com i'd be potentially up
for doing some some streaming there
uh this is a real tan i got i got tan
over the weekend
and uh it was it was crazy
haley says sir you need to add your
sound system to the class action lawsuit
against all machines we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines
while we were streaming someone sent me
trump's record skipping sound
[Laughter]
there you go yeah
mitt romney
that's a beautiful i might need that
uh really outdoing small fuzzy moss
there
david tanman that's exactly right that's
the new show david tan man
thanks hayley appreciate the super chat
we're about to get a new witness here
um
how do you request a free membership oh
boy guys you go to davidpakman.com
free membership okay
there's 694 people waiting for free
memberships right now
694 people give me a break i need 11 000
votes give me a break please
please
this is expected to go about another 45
minutes i think and um in terms of the
trial
it's weeks weeks weeks weeks ahead
yeah i i kind of should get you know
what's fuzzy what you could get me would
be
mitt romney
billy the cud
and jp jd mandel
those would be good
can a cat get a membership probably not
probably not i don't think that that
would be allowed
let's see if i've got another voicemail
for you fine people here
um
let's see what i've got
oh david uh i confess that uh back on
the campaign trail i believed uh tulsi
gabbard would i believe
how she represented her platform
as a uh
as a kind of a further left person
progressive
and uh
it's been uh i think months now since i
see all right let's continue
with the trial all right your next
witness then
thank you your honor uh plaintiff calls
aaron philade
also known as aaron borem philadelphi
and um miss herd's counsel begins the
questioning oh thank you it should be
interesting
2014 to 2016 time frame did you get the
video please correct there we go have
you communicated with anybody else from
mr depp's uh council other than ms
vasquez
uh not that i recall oh excuse me excuse
me i do
um
i don't remember his name i'm so sorry
i feel like i spoke with him
i don't know his last name
did you speak to or communicate with
adam waldman
perhaps i don't recall his last name
hmm
what are you suspecting
when that occurred
that
would have been
2019
because i had i had a newborn at that
time
so
maybe may june july something like that
2000 guys i'm getting a report that
destiny is talking about me on his
stream right now if that's true someone
please log it and email it and then
we'll look at it later okay yeah
okay
can you recall speaking to mr waldman at
all
yes and do you recall that when you were
uh communicating with mr waldman mr
waldman was mr depp's attorney
yes
miss vladi you're a trained nurse is
that correct
that's correct
do you have any specialties
well i haven't been working
you know like i used to but
previously
i was trained in addictions
and mental health
and when you say addictions
are there specific type of addictions
you were trained in
all but i primarily worked with chemical
dependency
and where did you receive training for
[Music]
addiction and mental health
different
employment places and then i became a
certified
registered
addictions nurse
you know who dr david kipper is bro
did you did you work for dr kipper
not directly
but
he would hire the agency
i provided
nursing services for
which was
turning point i believe
so i worked under his
guidance but not specifically for him
most the time there have been times
where i've worked specifically for him
okay when did you start working for uh
turning point nursing services or
whatever the name of that company was
i
don't recall my best guess would be
[Music]
somewhere between
2007 or eight
when did you start to begin to do any
work for dr kipper
i believe 2014.
can everybody hear her okay
what were the circumstances that started
you working for dr kipper in 2014
i recall correctly it would be
for services for ms heard
were you ever responsible for mr duff's
nursing care
while he was under the treatment of dr
kipper
it provided him with nerve scene care
[Music]
oh boy
this could get weird
so miss valadi i'm showing you what's
been marked as exhibit two to your
deposition
and
these are
you
these are ah tpd
16 929
through
16 9 59 and is that the paper document
do you have a set of the paper documents
you have in front of
you part of the
first page
and the first page you might have said
at the bottom also uh
k182
yes i have that okay
do you recognize these as your
what are these
these are
my nursing notes
for ms heard
yes
and and these are notes you created
yes
did you create these notes in the
ordinary course of business
yes okay
um
were you trained and how to prepare
these notes
yes
would you write these when
how long after you the visit would you
write up these notes
would depend sometimes i would keep
notes on my phone that i
would transfer to the word document
when i when i was in front of my laptop
and if not possible i would
do it
as soon as feasible
pleasable
and how often would you show these notes
dr visa
i don't recall at intervals but i don't
recall
um
so if you look at the first page
of the notes
um the first the first entry is august
27 2014 correct
yes
and
uh you wrote rn has been hired to
provide private nursing care for client
amber heard
right
right and rn refers to you correct
uh
and it's crazy that the connection's all
glitchy in a deposition i mean it's just
like this is crazy
um
throughout the notes and you say this
here amber heard would be referred to as
client or ah correct
all right
and and johnny depp would be referred to
as jd
would you agree that mr def and amber
would get into verbal arguments
you recall a general sense of
discord in the relationship
what do you mean by general sense of
discord
i just recall there being
disagreements
reconciliation and
kind of that repeating pattern
and would you be at times taking care of
amber because of this
the disagreements between mr def and
amber
i provided emotional support i was
not present with her often but it was
available
over the phone via text and sometimes in
person
do you recall that in march 2015
uh amber went to australia to be with mr
depp
yes i remember he went to australia as
to the dates i would
have to
look through documentation to ascertain
the exact dates
okay
and on exhibit two
this is your note of march 7th 2015.
that's correct
and you wrote a client notifies rn via
text of increasing anxiety
yes i wrote that
and then on 3 8 15 you wrote rn receive
report from debbie
rn
wbway correct
that's correct
do you recall what the report you
received was
on march
8th 2015 from debbie
i mean i'm just reading my notes sure
so to answer your question
no i don't recall
specifics of what the report would have
been
i assume
based on this note
that would have been a phone call
okay and it says client will be
returning to los angeles on march 9th
2015 accompanied by house manager ben do
you see that
yeah
do you have an understanding as to why
amber was leaving australia
in march of 2015
yes
i don't know if this is the exact timing
but
you know better than i there was an
incident in
australia
and they had to be misheard and mr jeff
had to be separated
um
so
ms heard returned
to los angeles for my my nursing notes
and i believe mr jeff must have stayed
in australia
what was your understanding as to why mr
deaf and amber had to be separated
it's hard to recall
specifics because i wasn't
there or involved at the time but became
involved again i remember
hearing from other people that there was
quite an argument
between the two
in australia
do you have any understanding if anyone
was injured
during um
the
argument between the argument between
amber and mr deb hmm physically injured
physically yeah
again i wasn't present so i'm only
speaking
as to what i recall
during that time period and what i
sort of remember hearing from others
and also
i just remember
mr depp's
finger was injured
i can't tell you specifically which one
but i remember there was an injury to
his finger
do you have any understanding as to how
his finger was injured
no
and then um
aaron you wrote the next note on march 9
2015 that says
rn and ct and touch via text and phone
calls
after client arrived at 1500
yes they wrote that
and 1500 that you're using military time
correct
that's correct so that would be 3 p.m
correct
and you wrote a client express feeling
quote sad
right
yes they wrote that do you recall what
amber was said about it approximately
march 9 2015
i can't speak today you know
i don't remember
specifically but i would assume based on
my march 8th note i would make the
assumption that
those feelings were in relation to
the relationship
issues
you wrote client states she would like
to discuss recent events between her and
husband with rn in private tomorrow
plans are made for rn to visit client at
her home tomorrow
yes i wrote that
do you recall
all the conversation you had with amber
regarding the events between her and mr
depp at this march around this march
night it seems the point of this would
be for amber heard's lawyers to show how
distraught amber heard was
and for johnny depp's lawyers to show
how fine amber heard was and that
clearly johnny depp wasn't doing
anything to her
admit did
did amber
express any um
fear of mr depp at this time
i don't recall i don't
i don't see that in this note so i i
can't speak to that
um and then the note for uh march 10
2015 you see that note
i do you can take this down
[Music]
we put up attachment 25 please
get
vaccinated before
ms valadi i'm showing you a text change
between
you and
whitney heard
on march 23rd 2015. do you see that
yes i do
and on march uh 23rd 2015 you
texted to whitney heard debbie just told
me what's going on and to check with you
is amber awake or fall asleep do you see
that
yeah
and then
miss heard wrote she finally fell asleep
you see that
yes
okay then you wrote thank goodness
she must be exhausted
i'm sorry just just to confirm this is
this is from
whitney heard not
amber heard correct
as as i understand it it says
is that your understanding
i assume thank you
and then you if you recall over
communicating with whitney hurt
via text or chat
that sounds familiar okay
and you wrote thank goodness she must be
exhausted you want me to come to the
loft or is she safe and sound asleep
you see that did you see that
okay
and then
whitney wrote safe question mark no
she's not
kept saying she wants to kill herself
you see that
see that
were you ever concerned about miss heard
safety as it relates to mr deb
so if she made comments
to me that she was not safe
i would
be concerned
about her to ensure that she was safe
yes do you recall miss her making
comments to you
about her safety
i remember a general sense
when
they
meaning misheard and mr jeff would have
arguments she would often have her
friends around her for support
but from a
[Music]
general
you know physical sense she was she was
always in a safe place
oh and you mean where you mean in a
general physical sense she was always in
a safe place what do you mean by that
meaning she was always
not always i should say often home often
surrounded with friends she had friends
that lived
right down the hallway from her so she
was
always supported
was was mr depp friends with marilyn
manson
yes i believe
miss valadi i'm showing you what's
marked as exhibit seven and these are um
texts
that mr dev produced between you and him
um and i'm focusing on this text message
of october 31st 2015. you see that
well so this text message between you
and whitney is on march 23rd 2015. you
see that yeah okay and if we go back to
exhibit two
and
i'll go back
um
um
there there's no entry for march 23rd
2015. you see that
not everything you did for miss hurt as
a as a nurse is reflected in these notes
correct
and the next notes we have are november
25th 2015.
do you know why there's
a long um
period where there's no notes
yes
perhaps i can shed some light
for you and everyone on the
relationship uh when i was first
hired to care for ms heard
i worked full-time you know i was
assigned
24 7 basically
and after a period of time i became
more part-time and on-call
and i was working with different clients
at the time so i would
how to put it i would not be working
regularly
but
would also be available if
an issue arose or a medication change
needed or things like that so
i would assume that would account for
this
this gap
why did you move from um
full-time to part-time
i don't know the exact answer but i i
assume
that's not my decision to make that's
usually the client and or treating
physician
okay so that's the first page of exhibit
two
yes thank you
pretty riveting stuff so if you can um
can you go down
to it's about the third
paragraph a little bit yes
her report from jd
which refers to mr jeff
debbie rn and dr kipper
client ah which is miss heard
has reportedly
been experiencing
increased anxiety and agitation recently
and has had several outbursts of anger
and rage
from what i remember
when i was involved in the case it was
to help assist ms heard
with some emotional
issues anxiety issues
in in attempts to
assist in layman's term kind of calming
things down a bit it is weird that you
get a nurse for primary anxiety when
normally you would get
either a psychologist a licensed
independent social worker
i don't know it's kind of weird isn't it
i do recall her
seeing her
very angry
i have to refer to my notes it was in
london so that would have been 2014.
and i believe it was in reference to
a violating incident where her phone had
been
packed and she was quite upset
i saw her angry
at that time and other times i don't
recall
were you in london with amber at the
time
yes
and how is how is amber showing her
anger
i
recall
loud
kind of elevated uh
voice
yelling
crying
[Music]
uh quite upset
do you recall receiving a call
from amber um
around december 16 2015 regarding
this argument between
mr depp and amber
you don't recall a specific phone call
do you would you doubt that a phone call
occurred
if you wrote it down in your notes
if i wrote it i don't doubt that it
occurred i just don't have memory of it
that's fair
and now you see the note on
december 17 2015
yes
and you wrote rn in contact with client
to notify her that she'd be able to
deliver medications to her home
aaron waited at the door for several
minutes after knocking
client greeted her in the door looking
disheveled
hair appeared unbrushed client appeared
weepy and sad
posture is slouched
client told rn about argument with
husband
r and over offered emotional support but
reminded client that rn could not stay
as was on duty with another client and
was only visiting in order to deliver
medication
per client she'd not been
she had not had contact with husband
since altercation
client had visible bright red blood
appearing at center of lower lip
when rn made client aware that she
actively was actively bleeding on her
lip client stated it was from
injuries sustained in the
and then it's blank you see that and
then we keep going down in the argument
between her
and her husband and that it continues to
bleed actively you wrote that
yes
and then you also wrote clients also
states
that her head is bruised and that she
lost clumps of hair and alternation
you wrote
that i assume so it's in my notes okay
and then you wrote aaron briefly looked
the client's scalp but was unable to
visualize the
hematoma's client had described
he wrote that
yes i would agree and and then you wrote
rn encourage clients to be seen by
physician dr kipper or go to emergency
urgent care
for thorough assessment you see that
i do
and then you wrote client states you
will contact dr kipper tomorrow
client is supported by friends rocky and
io who will be staying in clients home
with her you wrote that
i agree yes
okay
and then on december 18 2015 you wrote
client state shoot went to dr kipper's
office and was assessed by
np monroe t as dr kiffer was out of the
office you wrote that
yes
an np stands for nurse practitioner
that's correct
and do you understand when roti
stood for monroe tinker
yes
you recall mr dev ever forgot to take
any of his medication
a specific time or ever
in any time where you were working with
him
[Music]
i would say vaguely
yes
mr splatty i'm showing it's been marked
as exhibit 11
to your deposition which is
pilate 96
through
106. you see that
yes
you recall rece can you recall receiving
this text message right
a vague memory of this some redactions
you recall if you spoke to amber after
you received this text message
or at any time after you received this
text message around may 21st may 22nd
2016.
are you saying a phone call or just
i
i don't really recall
it could have happened you just don't
recall one way or the other
i would agree with that
and you received this picture from
amber
that's correct
what is this picture
[Music]
i was just asking if you could scroll
down well can we
if you rewind it just
heard
and does the picture show redness on
under mr miss her's eyes
you can ask answer as a lay person if
she has such an opinion
if you have an opinion one way or the
other you can let them know
i'm not an expert so
i mean there's
color on her face in different areas i
don't know what's what
he received this first picture
of amber at 12 36 am correct
that's the time stamp there
and you received another picture
at 12 36 a.m
it appears so
and who do you see in that picture
also misheard
and you received a third picture of
amber at 12 36 a.m
yes i fear so
and is that third picture of amber
yes that's new search
and you receive the fourth picture of
amber at 12 30 6 a.m
then yes
and and there's fourth i think so it's
clear the fourth picture is of amber
that's correct and you received that at
12 36 a.m
yes that's the time stamp
and these are pictures of
amber's face correct
yes that's a picture of her face and
neck
do you recall if you do you recall and
you were receiving those pictures
like i said i have a vague memory of of
this but i don't
specifically remember receiving it
um
okay
do you know if you reported
these pictures
or
what miss
heard reported to you to dr kipper
i would assume that
if any information
uh
was presented to me i would have
contacted dr kipper and you know how you
would have contacted dr pipper
no i
i depending on the date time i would
sometimes call email checks
[Music]
do you recall if you wrote nurse notes
for this incident
i don't recall
you want us to look at exhibit two
it's the nursing nurse yeah why don't we
do that
so there's notes for may 11 2016. you
see that
yeah
and then the next notes for may 26
2016. yes
okay
do you know why you didn't include notes
for may 21st 2016.
i don't know
and on may 26 he wrote a client texted
rn requesting ambien as she states she's
suffering from insomnia due to stress
and anxiety
client reports quote having the hardest
week of my life
end quote you wrote that yes and you
wrote client state she cannot deal with
the negative media publicity she has
received
surrounding the divorce she requested
from her husband jd
dr kipper notified
ambien 10 milligrams qhs prn 14 ordered
for dr kipper clients encouraged to make
appointment with dr kipper in office to
be assessed client did not respond you
wrote that
yes
mr i'm showing you what's been marked as
exhibit 12 to your deposition
which is
pilate 114 through 119.
um
you can take a look through them uh it
appears to be notes of your
of when you were mr depp's
nurse
as opposed to miss
heard
but feel free to take a look
that's correct i i
think these are
mr or excuse me my nursing notes in
relation to mr deb
so client now is mr depp correct
that's correct because
these nursing notes
are in reference to mr jeff yes that's
correct okay all right everybody we've
come to the end of my availability here
at quarter of as we've got to get into
some other stuff here in the studio
i'll cover more of this tomorrow and we
may have election results tomorrow night
we'll have the pennsylvania republican
senate debate on wednesday night we will
probably have the trump rally on friday
night obama uh and many other streams so
i appreciate everybody joining me you
can continue to watch this on any number
of other streams
uh i'm sure you find it all as
compelling as i do
and we'll be back with everybody
tomorrow